[Music]
sally cove at 19 cases are still high
all across the valley so how are those
testing lines looking a lot of people
head to local urgent cares to get their
results quickly madison kimbrough spoke
with care now urgent care today she
joins us live near tropicana and jones
with the latest tonight madison
this particular care now site is open 24
hours and according to the medical
director we spoke to earlier today
people coming in to test hasn't slowed
down at all our walk-in
rate has increased unlike what we see at
drive-thru testing sites it seems care
now urgent cares across the valley are
still seeing an influx of people coming
in to get tested we're seeing lines at
the beginning of our shifts and
throughout the day dr tyler says the
24-hour facility on tropicana and jones
along with their sites in the north las
vegas area tend to be the busiest with
the majority of people walking in to get
tested as opposed to going online to
check in which care now encourages but
with the increase in testing also comes
the increase in positive results i can
look back in november
uh of 2021 the the cova 19 test
positivity rate at our clinics was only
five percent but we look at where we are
now the test positivity for cover 19 up
to 45 percent uh and a lot of that is
driven by the immigrant
variant care now offers paid and
molecular testing with people getting
their results back in 15 minutes
and for clarification there is a fee to
test but if you have insurance you
should be reimbursed later on care now
has 17 locations across the valley and
they plan on opening one up near
centennial hills that's going to be in
late february reporting from tropicana
and jones madison kimbrough live local
now